My name is Aaron Karp and now
I'll be walking you through
changes that we are making to
campaign targeting in v201109.
So first, I'm going to talk
about the difference between
v201109 and v201101.
I'm gonna show you guys some
examples of what it looks like
in the old version and what it
looks like in the new version.
And then I'm gonna discuss a
couple of helper services that
we're also releasing that make
it easier to get different
campaign target types back from
the API so you don't have
to rely on the tables and
the documentation.
Similarly to how we were talking
about report fields
being available by API service,
now many of the
geo-targets, for example,
are available by
API service, as well.
Here's how things looked
in v201101.
At the campaign level within the
settings property, you had
Geo-target Type, Real Time
Bidding Settings.
You had these networks settings
about Google Search,
Google Search Network, Contact
Network, Contact Contextual,
Partner Search Network,
that sort of thing.
Within the campaign target
services, you have the Ad
Schedule Target, Language
Target, Platform Target,
Mobile Target, Geo Target,
and Demographic Target.
Here's what's happening
in v201109.
So all that's left on the
campaign target surface is the
Ad Schedule Target.
Language Target, Platform
Target, Mobile Target, Geo
Target, Demographic Target--
all gone.
Where did they go?
To the Campaign Criterion
Service.
What we're doing is we are
starting to treat all of these
different targeting parameters
the same way that we treat
keywords and placements--
as just another way of
determining who sees your ad.
Just like the keyword search
term helps identify a person
to show your ad to, same thing
with gender, or age range, or
mobile operating system.
Those are all criteria that
determine whether or not
someone is a good candidate
to see your ad and
possibly click through.
So here's a quick mapping
looking at the way things were
previously, the Ad Schedule
Target, the Country Target,
Mobile Platform Target.
We've moved them into this
criteria categorization.
For the most part, it's a
one-to-one mapping with the
exception of Geo Target, where
you can see city, country,
metro, province, et cetera, all
get moved into the same
location, criterion side.
In the process of moving our
targeting types into the
campaign criterion service, we
needed to have criterion ideas
for all these new
targeting types.
So looking at platform targets,
for example, we have
these three platform targeting
criteria--
desktop, high-end mobile,
and tablet.
What you'll notice is
interesting is that they have
unique, static criteria ID
values because there's only
one row in our criteria table
representing each of those
platform target types.
So let's look at a
response from the
campaign target service.
In v201101, if you did a
campaign target service .get
in the previous version, and
you were looking at the
language targets, you
might see what we
have at the top here.
Target type is language
target.
Language code is English.
In v201109, we're gonna do
campaign criterion service
.get, and we're gonna get back
an array of criteria objects.
Here we have criterion
xsi type is language.
It has that idea of 1,000, which
you'll remember from the
previous slide identifies
it as English.
We also have the code here, EN,
for the language, and some
other data to help you out.
Note that when you send this
XML to the API in order to
create a new criterion, you
don't actually have to send
the vast majority
of these fields.
All you really have to send is
the xsi type and the ID.
Let's look at one more example,
this time with
geo-targeting.
In the previous version of the
API, you would receive the
following target for
a province target.
Target type, province target.
Province code, US, Alabama.
In the new campaign criterion
service response, you'll get
the following.
Xsi type is location.
The ID is 21133.
And the rest of it is helpful
data that you might want to
have in response but doesn't
necessarily need to be passed
in by you when you actually
create one of these criteria.
You'll also notice that the
response contains a parent
locations object, our
parent location
elements in the XML here.
And that shows that the parent
of Alabama is 2840, which
corresponds to the
United States.
Let's look at the constant data
service, which, as you
might imagine, returns data
on various constants.
Right now it has two methods,
one of which is get language
criterion, and that's gonna
return an array of all the
different possible language
criteria that you
might want to target.
Here's a snippet of
the response.
First we have our English
language target, ID 1,000.
We have our German language
target, ID 1,001, French,
1,002, et cetera.
So you can use this instead of
hard coding languages and IDs
into your application.
If you wanted to refresh this
periodically, or even do it on
the fly, you have the option
of polling a up-to-the-date
list that matches exactly
what we have in
AdWords using this service.
We also have another new service
called the location
criterion service.
This one is like a search
service for matching different
geographic terms with the
corresponding AdWords objects.
In this example here, I'm going
to be searching for a
location using our nice, generic
selector format.
I'm gonna pass on a predicate
to search for where the
location name equals this set
of Chinese characters.
This also serves to show
how this service works
cross-language.
So what does the response look
like for this search?
Those Chinese characters
correspond to the city of
Beijing in China.
So we get back-- our criterion
type is any location where the
name is Beijing, display
type city.
And it also gives us
back the parents.
So we can tell from this, that
would be city of Beijing is
within the region of Beijing,
which is within
the country of China.
And we can get back the
canonical name as well right
here, which is Google
canonical localized
representation of Beijing,
in this case.
All right.
Let's look at a little bit
of a code example.
How would one actually
create one of these
new campaign criteria?
In this case, we're going to
create a tablet target, and
we're going to create a
geo-target for the country of
Mexico using PHP in this
particular case.
So we create our new platform
target object.
We set its ID.
Now, again, you can pull that
from your database.
You can pull that from our
ConstantData service.
Or you can just have it hard
coded in, as well.
We're gonna create a new
campaign criterion object
using this ID.
Pretty simple.
Then we're gonna do the
same exact thing
with the country targets.
A new location object.
We're going to create a campaign
criterion object that
encloses that location.
We're gonna add it to our array
of campaign criteria.
And then below is what you
guys are already familiar
with, basically setting the
operator as add and sending it
to the campaign criterion
service
with the mutate method.
So where can you find
these ideas?
Well, a couple of them
are available in the
ConstantData service.
But for everything else, we have
published lists of codes
down at the very bottom left
of the documentation page
under system codes.
You can see here, I have the
age ranges selected.
So these are the different
criterion IDs for all these
possible age range targets.
All right.
Thank you very much.